Peggy 18
you gonna come with me to Chicago you
don't trust me there's nothing I can do
now listen to me
I'm the one who decides your fate
mr. man others
I'm looking at the network as we speak
back in welcome to watchdogs an open
world action-adventure game set in
Chicago a hyper-connected city right
with opportunities from the skyscrapers
of mad mile to the calm countryside of
Pawnee explore all of what each of
Chicago's six unique massive districts
as the army
you play as Aiden Pearce a brilliant
hacker whose criminal past led to a
violent family tragedy while seeking
justice for those events you will turn
the city into your weapon by hacking
into CTOs a central operating system
managing every piece of technology and
monitoring every citizen the power of
CTOs grows every day but only a handful
of elite hackers and crooked officials
have been able to exploit it thus far
you have the power to hack into CTOs and
your cell phone
to gain access into anyone's digital
life use over 60 different skills and
powerful hacks to access bank accounts
personal data sensitive secrets and more
now is there anything else I can take a
look at in watchdogs
in the CTOs opens up a world of
opportunity manipulate every aspect of
the city infrastructure to your own ends
disrupt traffic [ __ ] communication or
simply flip the cities off switch one
massive blackout use your hacking
abilities for good or bad it's up to you
trace criminal activities and intervene
or turn a blind eye stop illegal convoys
from reaching
or infiltrate organizations to stop
Chicago's most dangerous criminals but
beware
every decision influences your citywide
reputation and you never know who's
watching do not approach the suspect he
is considered armed and dangerous that
isn't making us the best of friends in
the hyper-connected city of Chicago your
personal connections can be just as
important as your digital ones you'll
need good friends to protect yourself
from great enemies meet Clara Lille a
fellow hacker was as dangerous as she is
seductive she's the trapdoor spider you
never saw coming you're not quite what I
expect him and you're exactly as I
expected hi who are they
this is Jordi chin your business
associate you need a body to disappear
or an enemy to talk you call Jordi these
people just had a simple chain lock on
their door I guess they want to have a
good look at the pizza guy before they
open it all the way he opens the door
this much there's a chain right there I
slip them in and snip and guess what
it's not the pizza guy and then there's
team or whoever resourceful pyromania
ebal plays by his own rules in corporate
espionage good cop big explosions honey
we can't all be pretty in this game
but not everyone in Chicago is this
helpful take Iraq seasoned War vet knows
the battles of the future will be won
through technology
he's also the ambitious leader of a
black place Roig and it cost him you
business what do you think is gonna win
between you at the top of Chicago's
criminal network is lucky Quinn he's
fought for everything he controls he's
still fighting serious has taught me not
to be manipulated not to back down in
the world of watchdogs your obvious
enemies aren't your only ones another
player can always be lurking beside your
game learning the line between a single
multi-player contracts can be placed on
your head inviting other online players
to invade your single-player game to try
and hack you they reach your network you
can run fight or turn the tables with a
counter hack you can also explore your
single-player world to find online
contracts of your own if you accept
you'll immediately enter another
player's game and you can try to hack
him before he even knows you're there in
watch dogs multiplayer features blend
seamlessly with the single-player
experience everything and everyone is
connected recruit fellow hackers and
challenge other crews online in game
modes like decryption combat where speed
and teamwork are required to seize data
before the enemy can or go head-to-head
with other crews and free roam mode as
you battle in the shadows of Chicago's
iconic buildings and landmarks
turn your phone or tablet into the most
powerful weapon in and out of the game
with the CTOs companion app available on
Android and iOS through the app you
could hack your friends console games
creating distractions and triggering the
city's house challenge your counselor
friends to a high speed race through the
streets of Chicago on CTOs mobile you
act as the Chicago PD controlling
traffic lights road blockers and even a
helicopter to interfere with the console
players race through the city
experience a unique progression with
more than 45 upgrades for the police
arsenal I hope you have an invitation or
you're dead I'm the driver to get around
the sprawling metropolis of Chicago
you'll need a ride
that comes your way there were over 70
kinds of vehicles you can dab with your
hacking skills or steal by cores
download anyone's vehicle registration
to have their car deliver to you with
the cars on-demand app once you find
your ideal ride open the contracts app
to pick up some side work is a wheelman
run transporter jobs
act as a decoy intercept sensitive
material or jump online and work the
street racing circuits around the city
to win cars and cash
take a look at this in watchdog's your
phone is not only a powerful hacking
tool but also a virtual door to a lot of
fun
customize your audio playlist as you
roam Chicago check in at local hotspots
and join a wide variety of City games
you can also play minigames like
invasion that turns Chicago into a
sci-fi shooter with an 8-bit twist or
test your roof running and jumping
skills in cash run a citywide hunt for
digital coins you can even make courses
to share with the world also on your
phone are apps that trigger mind-bending
digital trips download your trip of
choice for a whole new watchdog's
experience like rampaging through a
hellish version of Chicago in madness
fuel your ride with the souls of the
Dead to outrun the fiery eyed demons hot
on your tail
or trip out as you outlast waves of
police as a six-legged machine spider
tank destruction scale buildings smash
pause or tear up the town with your
Gatling gun check out all the in-game
apps for even more digital trips Master
them to make your way up the
leaderboards noting a lot of things that
don't add up
hey you called me here I wouldn't know
where to begin
that's just the small taste of the
massive open world an unlimited hackable
action that awaits you in watchdogs when
the lights go out bad things tend to
happen